de sérieux dégâts sur
leur passage. Une fugue qui
intrigue les scientifiques.
Alexie André-Bélisle.
- Ils ont l'air paisible
lorsqu'ils se reposent.
Mais ces quinze éléphants
sauvages, qui sont sur la route
depuis la mi-avril, causent
en fait toute une commotion
en Chine parce qu'ils n'hésitent
pas à traverser des villages.
"J'avais peur. Nous sommes
sortis et avons vu un éléphant
d'environ 3 mètres de haut.
Un éléphanteau s'est même heurté
à notre mur avant de s'enfuir",
raconte cette villageoise.
Le troupeau a déjà parcouru
500 kilomètres vers le nord.
Ces pachydermes voyagent
à la manière d'un groupe
de rock stars : ils ont leur
propre personnel de sécurité et
se font livrer leur repas.
C'est qu'avec une population
de seulement 300 bêtes,
les éléphants d'Asie sont
une espèce protégée.
Les accompagnateurs sont là
pour s'assurer de leur sécurité,
mais aussi pour éviter qu'ils ne
fassent plus de dommages.
Car depuis le début de leur
périple, les éléphants ont
ravagé 56 hectares de culture
et causé l'équivalent de plus
d'un million de dollars de
dégâts.
Pour éviter qu'ils n'atteignent
d'autres villages, des véhicules
ont été déployés pour bloquer
des routes.
"Les agents de police ont dit
qu'ils avaient besoin de
camions. Tant qu'on aura besoin
de moi, je resterai ici",
explique ce camionneur.
Les zoologues ne comprennent
pas ce qui a amené les éléphants
à parcourir une si longue
distance, mais ils constatent
que depuis plusieurs années,
ces bêtes ont tendance
à se rapprocher des villages.
C'est que l'émergence
de plantations de caoutchouc
les privent des plantes
qu'ils mangent habituellement
dans leur réserve naturelle.
D'ailleurs, un autre troupeau
est aussi sorti de son habitat,
mais pour le moment,